hey guys I'm Cory I am going a month
without drinking and I'm going to
document it if I'm being straight up
about this I'm not excited I like to
drink I think it's fun it's something
that my friends do we go out and we grab
some beers and it's just how we engage
with each other I think for a while
there I was getting really overwhelmed
with the stress of life and a
relationship in school and work and I
would deal with that stress by drinking
and trying to numb that and I'm
realizing that that's not a way for me
to handle this and I need to take a
little break here we go
[Music]
my boyfriend Cory is amazing he's
recently gone back to school for
business
he works at one of my favorite bars in
Los Angeles and he still finds time to
collaborate with me on buzzy projects
not about being for or against drinking
this is something that makes sense for
him personally to try and I hope it's a
good first 30 days okay so today is day
1 I got off work and I definitely
thought about routine or I have beer at
the house and I'm gonna get it but stay
one man sack up so I'm putting this on
the fridge so whenever I gotta open this
bad boy and think about it
have this to not drink don't do it yeah
big dumb idiot so I'm just not getting
off work it's like midnight and normally
I would go home and have my drinks but
tonight I got to change up my routine
and I'm coming over to Becky's because
nothing helps being sober like having a
hot woman in your bed or her pet or
whoever's bed you get it being around
drunk people some of them are really
annoying and other my friends are
actually some lumber pretty funny drunks
and at home time to get around them so
me and a buddy of mine came to a bar
today and I'm drinking a water
however the bartender is a friend and
this is a guy delicious
I found that I crave that feeling of
just popping something open and having
sup to drink so I've tried several
non-alcoholic beers we are doing the
non-alcoholic taste test
so the second one is Becks alright
alright
cheers Cheers it is like a light beer
but likes weirdly sweet not a fan of
this no most of them are not good but I
found what I like the O'Doul's amber
alright Cheers
alright just like taste like beer right
yeah with that yeah this is heaven the
cravings pretty well Cheers of that no
it's great when you're not drinking
waking up waking up scribble it doesn't
suck nearly as bad as it did oh I'm
actually feeling pretty good I feel
better focused
I feel very clear it's been really nice
actually I'm annoyed last night was the
first night that we went out with a
large group of people with Korey not
drinking and I could not believe what
happened there was a point in the night
when a couple the regulars at the bar
are asking him again and again like wait
are you really not drinking
and once he says yet I'm not they
actually vote him
[Music]
sold out of the bars completely expected
some of my friends to be dicks and you
know what some of them really are dicks
she did not let it go throughout the
entire night I really hope that this
subsides so tonight Corey had this huge
test a lot was resting on this stupid
test I just got a call from him that got
me really worried so he briefly called
me and said that he failed the test and
that he may drink he doesn't know and
then I tried calling him back and his
phone was off so I just got out of the
test and I failed it I mean I bombed it
I worked so hard and the last thing I
want to do right now
he's do this stupid [ __ ] video think
about how I failed
I just want to get beer just want to go
home relax just [ __ ] forget about
this test [ __ ] look
so I am very happy to be doing this long
today so last night after Corey and I
talked on the phone
two hours later called me back he told
me that when he got home last night he
was furious that he was so tempted to
drink but instead he threw on some gym
clothes left the house and went for this
long
angry run so I'm just not getting back
from my run and today was easily the
hardest day that I've had so far uh
every instinct in me was like go home
and have a beer and instead I went for a
run alcohol is a very short term
solution to what our very long-term
issues today instead of having that beer
demonstrated how committed I am to my
future and for that like I feel really
good one thing I've noticed a lot is my
anxieties a lot better and I remember
thinking when I was drinking that that
would kind of like calm me what I
noticed was that the next morning mine's
already rebounded kind of worse and so
I'm noticing that my levels are a lot
more stable I think that I've noticed
that your face is less red I've noticed
that too
have you really yeah okay so that I
found something interesting I read that
alcohol is dehydrating which causes
inflammation or enlarged blood vessels
in the face this is what causes redness
from drinking I notice that you just get
red a lot less yeah so look at holy [ __ ]
look at that look I'm glad I don't look
like a stop sign and go look look dumb
I did I look dumb yeah I did that one
photo looks real tough
all right so we're three weeks and I've
learned a few things one I'm gonna miss
out on some things from time to time
it's just gonna have to be okay like you
know there's got to be a point in the
night we just call it for some of my
friends it's like three beers once I hit
that three beer mark you don't know that
I'm here or not so I'm just gonna go
home
but I also learned and most importantly
I don't have to be drinking to have a
good time and so what my boys at a bar
engage and still enjoy myself
how you doing though I'm killing I'm
very gonna water not taking a photo of
him before we started this he had
mentioned that he'd wanted to get better
shape is I took like a before photo so
we took that same exact or roughly same
exact position photo and look at the
difference it's crazy
within just like four weeks of not
drinking and really only working out
okay okay this a man this just happened
passively well I'm happy about it it's
been challenging but it's been really
good in ways that I didn't even expect
so my relationships have gotten
tremendously better sex is more fun cuz
I'm not like worried about my gut I
definitely noticed like a confidence
boost at school and I'm much more able
to learn Chinese incredible but it was
difficult to write the Aleut but once
that happened the long-term goals became
a lot more apparent I was able to not
just think about okay what do I want
physically but what do I want
professionally what do I want five years
down the road I could think in a much
bigger scale
[Music]
yeah I'm feeling yes look at these brave
baby my yeah that's right Stephen
Hawking a cup
okay thanks like a really big babies a
genius across the border I just feel a
lot more like me yeah yeah I'm just me
unfortunately
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]